I think so many genders say you know I
don't want to have families I don't want
to have kids whenever I get married and
have kids because that's always like the
thing that I've wanted most is to be a
mom my mom is just an incredible example
of what a mother can be and she just
dedicated her life to being a really
really engaged parent I was like that's
what I want to do I want to be able to
build humans I always grew up planning
on having at least two kids and then I
heard from meet Kevin and I was like why
do you want to have so many kids he's
like think about it this my man they're
your best friends why would you not want
more best friends yeah and I was like
well that makes sense